vor zwei jahren habe ich auf meinem
kanal unzählige addario videos
hochgeladen
das spiel dort mega im trend war ich war
mega gut denke ich war echt scheiße
eigentlich auf jeden fall habe ich im
internet ein spiel gefunden dass sie die
dot.com heiß und es ist agrio in 3d
wir nehmen als nicknamen einfach mal
locker neben losgehen klicken of play
und wir sehen schon wenn ich jetzt wie
drücke damit das ganze immer mehr so in
die normale agrio an sich gehen so geht
es in die richtung und mit den a und d
tasten kann ich mich hier so ein
bisschen bewegen also wir haben einmal
diese möglichkeit hat hier mit via sd so
ein bisschen zu arbeiten und dass sich
so ein bisschen anzuschauen oder halt
hier mit dem mauszeiger einfach so ein
bisschen umher zu gehen es sind alle
funktionen drin vorhanden die es auch im
echten mein gott roadkill alter es sind
alle funktionen drin vorhanden die es
auch im richtigen agrio gibt also ich
kann mich auch teilen ich kann andere
leute auftreten es gibt ja auch ein
scoreboard mit den top players
hindernisse sind hier als bäume
dargestellt und die mauer hier stellt zu
müssen den spielfeldrand da ich werde
das jetzt einfach mal so machen dass ich
die maus war sie da oben immer lassen
und mit denen wir es die tast mich hier
so ein bisschen rum rangiere ich habe
früher richtig krass gefeiert also es
war ja früher irgendwie neu heraus wo es
gezockt habe habe es dann auch
zwischenzeitlich mal mit anderen
youtuber mal gezockt und ja ich war
eigentlich nie wirklich gut ich werde
mich jetzt mal teilen genauso damit ich
jetzt mal hier hinten so ein bisschen
schneller wachsen beziehungsweise
doppelt so schön der so viel von dem
futter ja einsammeln kann es ist in
bayern sowie die tatsächlich schwieriger
was versieht wenn ich irgendwann durch
den baum gehe ich einfach durch es ist
in diesem spiel wirklich schwieriger
sich einen überblick zu verschaffen also
es kann sein dass hinter mir jetzt einer
ist dass sicherheit nicht weil hinter
mir gott nein du schaust ihm kommt
freunde ich weiß nicht wo ich hinter mir
hinfahre so bei dem normalen addario da
hat man dann immer noch so ein bisschen
der auswahlmöglichkeit und sieht halt
genau kate jetzt exakt wie h m oder der
also genau hinter mir oder ist ein
fetter als der erste ein score von
22.700 2
das schaffe ich definitiv auch mein
score ist gerade 118 bisher hatten wir
noch keinen richtigen gegner kontakt
aber es spielen doch ehrlich gesagt
relativ wenig leute das spiel also hier
begegne ich jetzt auch sehr wenig leuten
die ganze server wand freiberga rio muss
meiner teilweise stunden warten damit
man spielen konnte die zeit jetzt
einfach mal um so ein bisschen zu lagern
und zwar wenn ich das video gerade sieht
ist ich weiß gar nicht welcher tag auf
jeden fall produziere ich gerade videos
vor und das wochenende jetzt war ich in
münchen bzw
hier das video sehen bin ich glaub ich
sogar immer noch in münchen und wieso
war ich primären münchen natürlich auch
ein bisschen wegen dem oktoberfest aber
auch weil meine neue pizza in münchen
produziert wird und einige dachten es
sei wirklich von mir ein scherz gewesen
ist wird herausbringen mitte oktober
kommt von mir eine pizza in die
supermärkte und da wollte ich jetzt mal
ganz kurz was zu sagen weil träsch hatte
darüber schon berichtet und er hatte so
gesagt so erfreut sich auch da drauf und
so ich hatte mit ihm auch schon privat
und im interview mal darüber privaten im
interview ostring auch irgendwie fällt
hat sich im radio bei einem interview
mit ihm zu gast war hatte er auch schon
gesagt hey du bringst wirklich ne pizza
heraus und ich nur oh mein gott kann ich
denn da vorne auf essen der winter hält
zu joel war das jetzt wirklich kein
scherz ist und die pizza herausbringt
und ich so einen echten ich habe das
schon ich bock drauf noch mal der erste
ja ich bin auch schon mega gehabt alter
ich wenn mir safe meine holen mal gucken
wie die so ist und dann hat recht wie
das jetzt halt auch in der neuen folge
whatsup erwähnt dass ich eine pizza
rausbringe und da natürlich die youtube
community ist immer sehr negativ
gegenüber wenn die youtuber irgendwas
rausbringen die meisten kommentare da
waren so in etwa ja soll ich eine pizza
rausbringen ist er sein ding aber die
pcs stinknormale margarita und das macht
mich so ein bisschen traurig weil meine
damen und herren ich habe wirklich
versucht also die pizza die rauskommt
ist eine normale margarita also sieht
eine steinofenpizza sie ist größer als
normale pizzen also es ist schon eine
geile rapids als andere pizzen das sind
wo das hat sich gelohnt es ist auf jeden
fall eine margherita soll den habe ich
jetzt auch gegessen und was ich
eigentlich sagen wollte war hat viele
meinten halte das ist total und kreativ
einmal geriet soll er halt
salamischeiben draufmachen mit dem
smiley oder käse in smiley form dortmann
ich hab's ich wollte es freunde ich weiß
ja dass alle nicht verstehen also ich
hab's euch jetzt ja auch schon häufig
gesagt aber
solche maschinen zu entwickeln die
speziell salamis speziell anordnen oder
den käse die spezielle anordnung für
hunderttausende von pizzen
das kostet millionen deswegen haben wir
halt gesagt er wir starten erst mal mit
einer ganz normalen margherita schauen
wie das überhaupt ankommen denn luca ne
pizza rausbringen es kann ja auch sein
dass die alle pizza hast wenn die pizza
dann raus ist und wir sehen wirklich
okay ja bock darauf ihr bock auf die
pizza euch gefällt die euch schmeckt die
dann nehmen wir wirklich eine menge geld
in der hand um dann wirklich zum zweiten
eine zweite edition machen die alle
dementsprechend ein krasser ist also das
zu beginn ist jetzt erst mal quasi so
einen test laufen mit einer normalen
margherita da ist halt ein limitierter
smiley und so 3000 von 300.000 stück
schon unterschrieben haben besonderes
karton design mega simpel man kann die
karton aufstand und als teller benutzen
also wir haben uns das schon so ein paar
witzige gedanken gemacht die sache ist
halt allerdings nur wie gesagt das ist
jetzt erstmal so ein testlauf und ja
weil ich dass ich jetzt für eine million
euro mehrere maschinen kaufen um so eine
neuproduktion gründe oder kauft es
keiner und ich bin bereit und kann ich
mir leben es ist schon risiko was ich
damit ein gehe aber was ich jetzt
einfach sagen wollte war haye wartet mal
den oktober ab kauft euch vielleicht mal
die pizza die kosten ich weiß nicht
genau wie viel vielleicht 399 oder
irgendwie so es ist jetzt meine ansicht
nach echt nicht die welt und danach
könnt ihr immer noch beurteilen ob sie
es schmeckt ob sie euch nicht merkt ob
jetzt gut findet ob ihr das nicht gut
findet und jetzt habe ich glaube ich
genug geredet in der tat wir haben einen
score von 390 das heißt wir können jetzt
eigentlich schon mal ein bisschen
konkurrenzfähig hervorgehen mein ziel
ist es auf jeden fall den kollegen hier
vorne zu essen also ich weiß nicht ob
ich dafür groß genug bin dass ich mich
jetzt teile dass ich den dann irgendwie
konsumieren kann ich sage die ganze zeit
konsumiert sich heute behindere aber ich
werde ihn jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
so lang verfolgen bis wir zumindest am
rand angekommen sind mir ist es jetzt
scheißegal was wird über mich denkst
viel komischer volleyball wohin war ja
auch einer mit volleyball der hat er
wollte ich auch essen fand ich auch
nicht so gut
oh danke ich glaube ich bin groß genug
dass wenn ich jetzt auf ihn zugehen dass
ich nicht teilen kann getestet jetzt
einfach mal komm komm komm dicke freunde
ich bin gut der letzte der rangliste da
hat einen score von 1336 wir haben
gerade einen score von 961 9 und was das
sind ich glaube dass es bei bayer um für
die hier so ist das desto größer man ist
desto schneller verliert man quasi seine
punkte wieder scheiße können habe ich
gar nicht gedacht nach vorne haben wir
auch wieder einen kollegen den mir
definitiv essen können die sache ist nur
dass ich ein bisschen angst habe mich zu
splitten weil hier vorne über aber noch
andere leute sind ein paar sekunden
später schießt doch nicht wahr
das ist doch nicht wahr alter was ist
das turnier für eine scheiße als wenn er
schneller als als sehe ich ich ziehe
mich mal wieder zusammen hier vorne und
luca ist immer noch auf dem weg den nach
vorne zu essen ich weiß nicht ob ich mit
einem space da jetzt hin komme ich werde
es einfach so machen wie vorhin ich
werde ihnen einfach so lang verfolgen
bis einfach keine chance mehr hat
deshalb hinten irgendwo die mauer
auftaucht dann bringe ich ihn quasi in
die enge
2000 jahre später wo gott freunde wir
sind hier bei der mauer angekommen der
kleine knabe da vorne weil es gar nicht
mal richtig hingehen soll ich glaube hat
auch keine chance mehr gegen mich und er
macht auch gar nichts mehr
aber ich muss mich gar nicht pflücken ok
ich muss mich doch blöd wenn halt so als
würden wir gleich groß sind will er mich
verarschen legal wenn jetzt irgend ein
größerer ankommen und uns auf rissen
alter wir sind einfach komplett am arsch
das hätte ich nie gedacht dass er
plötzlich größer ist als ich all das
kann doch nicht wahr sein ich habe aber
jetzt eine ganz gute taktikfreunde er
bleibt einfach so lange
bis ich mich quasi wieder zusammenziehen
kann genau die jetzt dreht sich wieder
auf und wir sind in der rangliste alter
was los ist es echt krass ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass ich hier im ersten
teil direkt in die top ten komme jetzt
können auch risiko gehen und noch ein
paar kleinere hier fressen zum beispiel
die das ist doch nicht war der galt wenn
er nicht mit rein kommt ich trinke ihn
jetzt auch wieder so ein bisschen gegen
die mauer jetzt muss ich halt flink sein
also ich weiß nicht genau wo er hingeht
er geht auf jeden fall gegen die mauer
ich glaube er sieht ein dass er keine
chance hat und jetzt ich bin kein platz
vorgegangen jetzt gerade hat sich
aktualität meine damen und herren bin
gerade platzierten der erst hat als
20.000 ha da komme ich doch nie ran
mein ziel habe ich auf jeden fall
erreicht das war einfach nur in die top
ten zu kommen meint sports singt jetzt
halt schon wieder drastisch da vorne ist
futter freunde
oh mein gott da ist der erste alter was
geht ab man vom bakom dicker kommen
nein wir sind gleich groß alter was eine
scheiße man jetzt safe gesagt dass ich
größer bin als dieser cup fußballalter
wenn ich ein stückchen größer gewesen
wäre ich einfach 3000 gehabt und werden
ihnen die vierter gewesen oder so
an dieser klare hoffen halt da ich
verfolgt jetzt hier wieder meine taktik
dass ich zurzeit natürlich ein bisschen
schneller unterwegs bin aber jetzt das
wollte ich so nice freunde nice nice
nice das war eine richtig gute aktion
gar nicht bin fünfter
vielleicht kann ich da was reißen also
laut der rangliste habe ich mehr oder
weniger doppelt so viele punkte wie
dieser fußball vor mir erst auf platz
zehn nicht genug platz sechs aber ich
habe ein bisschen angst mich total
freunde und helfer haben wir die
nächsten aufgefressen jetzt musste ich
gleich ganz schnell sein und zwar wenn
sich meine beiden jungs hier gleich
zusammenziehen da muss sich schnell auf
den fussball draufgehen hörbarer fressen
pikachu eben da vorne ist fressen oh
mein gott wurden schon freunde gott
schonfrist ihn auf alter presse team
aufbauen das geld mal der letzte aktion
ihr sein wenn er sich zusammenzieht wie
scheiße ist dass er sich wahrscheinlich
zuerst zusammenzieht weil er sich auch
vorhin schon zuerst gesplittet hat jacke
alter hat er mir gleich groß
wahrscheinlich ja genau acht mann schade
das wäre eine coole aktion gewesen
disney was freundlich wird das video an
dieser stelle auch beenden das heißt die
spende mich jetzt an diese personen und
erst damit jetzt erwarte wenn sich das
heer update erst zweiter mit 7800 schau
dort an dicht
das war es jetzt auch vom wieder meine
damen und herren es euch gefallen habe
ich mich über einen like freund ich
wollte einfach mal addario in 3d zocken
und sonst würde ich jetzt sagen meine
damen und herren jetzt kommt das dorf
sich alle immer bei einem luca video
freuen nämlich das ende
das auto kommt jetzt
hier können jetzt jemand einen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten einen schock
aus schenkungen jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und benny schon abonnent
zeit könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]